foreign
I have actually climbed ice with a steak
Knife once I did it as a joke but there
are already holes in there and stuff so
no that dagger would not work my name is
Will Gad and I'm a professional ice
climber Red Bull athlete from Canmore
Alberta and I've been ice climbing for
almost 40 years today we're going to be
looking at ice climbing scenes in movies
and judge how real they are
you wouldn't be climbing together like
this because if one person falls off
you're kind of all gonna die simult
climbing is a tactic you use on
relatively easy terrain like maybe 50 60
degree terrain and it's just in case
something catastrophic goes wrong it's
high risk it's not something you you
generally want to do and you definitely
don't want to do it when you're scaling
the side of like this immense piece of
ice
foreign
you get cracks like that that go really
frightening distances I've had it
fracture like 30 feet horizontally so
it's a bit exaggerated but not that much
actually I saw that seat and I was like
ah but most Ice Climbers don't climb and
train like that you kind of have to be
weird to go there okay it's totally
unrealistic in every other way but at
least that part was kind of real
oh stop stop stop okay so that rope does
not stretch they would be cut in half
worst case scenario by the Rope or they
would break every major organ in their
bodies it's like a steel cable imagine
hooking yourself off a building tied to
a steel cable it's just not going to go
well so modern climbing ropes are
basically bungees and they elongate and
absorb the impact slowly specifically so
you don't break your internal organs
this is not a survivable situation and
that's just assuming the person up top
there could actually hold the impact
which they can't they would get yanked
off so fast
expensive
when you're hanging on a rope in space
it's really hard to generate lateral
momentum like this pretty much
impossible I've tried it a lot of times
so it doesn't matter how much you jerk
and twist you just sort of end up going
in a circle on the end of the Rope it's
one this is totally unrealistic and
never gonna never gonna happen
[Music]
as a mountaineer when you self-rest you
flip onto your stomach you dig your toes
in which buddy doesn't do when he's
sliding down here just if he would have
stopped this really fast if he just dug
his toes in right away you know his pick
is just ripping through the snow the
whole time when he does self-rest
somehow it holds in that situation
I always love it in scenes like this
when they say hang on like
if you let go it's super sunny out why
are her sunglasses on her head
she would be snow blind in like 10
seconds there's so many things that are
unbelievable but that's almost the most
unbelievable thing you definitely have
your sunglasses over your eyes at this
point
and when you break a cornice like that
it breaks when you get a fracture in
snow like that it goes it you don't get
kind of a second chance unfortunately
and having been in that situation where
it broke I ran the other way at speed
get away from there and she's like I'll
just keep standing here
that not really what you want to be
doing there
oh yeah so that's not gonna work you're
not gonna put your pick gently into the
snow and then have it hold anything it's
just gonna rip through like crazy maybe
if you pounded it in with like a big
hammer and it was you know where ice you
get
you know
a sort of okay emergency anchor but no
that's not gonna work
I've done things like that jumping from
one desert tower for example to another
you can do things sort of like that what
you can't do is fall like what looks
like let's use the most conservative
number we can 30 feet vertically
and stick your ice tools into rock
and then not completely blow both your
arms out of the sockets say you can hang
on to the ice tools like let's say that
somehow in your forearms you got the
juice you can hang on to those ice tools
I keep picturing this set of arms on the
wall while his body is somewhere
thousands of feet below that's what
would happen you would just rip
everything out and be like it's in the
negatives like if the other ones are
like one or two there's not enough room
in that scale to go low and the threat
at lost was ended this train is really
cool
so if anybody knows where this is and
it's real please send me an email I'd
like to have a go at that
she seems very nice but she's gonna die
that dagger is not going to go into the
ice like that it can be kind of like
trying to split firewood by pushing the
ax head into the wood with your hands
you gotta swing it and there's no force
in that dagger you just can't move fast
enough this is designed to swing really
fast into ice it's got a razor-sharp
point on it it's it's it's a weapon you
want this not not the ice dagger scene
that is just flat out not gonna work you
certainly couldn't jump laterally stick
it in and not die all this metal that's
gotta be so cool she's got like
chainmail on her head she's going to get
frostbite from that
okay where's what are they hanging on to
hang on stop for a second but that
person has their hand on the ice and
then look where the left ice tool is
there it's just dangling like that is
not the way forward you want to have
that in your hand you're not just gonna
latch onto the ice you can climb ice
without an ice tool but if you have one
you're sure going to want to use it but
I just loved how the ice tool is just
daggling there it's like ah we don't
need ice tools
that's something that's like a really
big Hazard nice climbing is you have to
think about where the ice you knock off
is gonna go that's like ice climbing
101. I have seen this happen in real
life it's usually involving Ice Climbers
from warm places you gotta put the
belays out of the way of falling ice
it's really important and then they get
hit in the face with ice and like oh man
you hit me in the face with ice like
don't stand in the way of the fall like
ice so and then in terms of the
technology or believability yeah we're
down in the the one two gutter rage here
foreign
so I really like this one because this
one actually happened base jumpers have
hugged themselves and gotten stuck on
cliffs regularly you know my friends on
the search and rescue crew here where I
live and then in other places they they
deal with this not you know it's it's
not never it's like a couple times a
season somebody's gonna do this
somewhere
foreign
this has got to hurt your foot like
there's a knife in there I can't see
this going well kicking the ice this is
not a good idea but yeah and I I have
actually climbed ice with a steak Knife
once I did it as a joke but there are
already holes in there and stuff so no
that dagger would not work
you need about two centimeters or an
inch of ice to climb it in a vertical
setting if you're really good I'm pretty
sure with like throwing knives you'd
probably need a bit more than that that
ice looks more like almost what we would
call their gla or or just very thin ice
and yeah that's not gonna work but I
love the creativity
I've actually had this happen sheep do
show up in climbing areas and they're a
real Hazard because they knock rocks off
on you I actually almost got killed this
way this herd of sheep showed up at the
top of the cliff and and they're running
around up there and they're knocking
rocks off and we all had to run into the
cliffs the Sheep don't move like this in
this train they don't have crampons on
their feet they're not moving like this
they're they're really good but they're
not that good
oh yeah hold up hold up what he's just
found there is actually one of the
biggest hazards
that's that you can't see in ice
climbing you kind of have to develop a
feel for it and it's called an onion
skin and what happens is you get snow on
a Ledge like that and then the water
from the ice climb keeps falling on top
and it makes a new layer of ice so it's
got snow underneath and it's got
um ice on top of it and it'll make like
layers just like that and this is a
little overdone ice doesn't just fail
like this but it's it's sort of
plausible I actually had something like
this kind of happen where an onion skin
broke and kind of wound up running in
place as this onion skin shot out from
underneath me so it's it's not exactly
like this but it you know kind of
realistic ice climbing instruction was
level was poor I'm gonna go three
you can tell by their movements these
are people that have actually ice climb
I think one of them is my friend Barry
Blanchard it's pretty old school and
they're Hamming it up hard for the
camera legs are out like out like this
to the side you don't normally ice climb
like that but it looks good on
television I have done that exact move
more than once on camera I can hear the
director yelling get more limb
separation to him you know that's like
the classic line but their feet aren't
blowing their feet are generally about
shoulder width apart and underneath them
it's like in any sport when your feet go
way out to the sides bad things are
gonna happen
so I think in this scene they're
training for the ice climbing part of
climbing K2 mountaineering is about
getting to the top of mountains but you
gotta have skills on rock and on Ice
different sort of mediums that you
travel on but in terms of the technique
and tactic to use this is all pretty
realistic you know you might not be
doing this form of steep climbing on K2
but you'd be doing something similar to
it
the whole camera is tilted to make it
look steeper and you can tell because
you can see the pack straps hanging down
they're not hanging down the right way
they're hanging down toward the ground
on this one
they're kind of using weird combinations
and so they've got a technical tool in
one hand and a longer mountaineering ice
ax in the other and the technical ice
climbing tools tend to be
um very organized for the pick to go
into ice well whereas the Mountaineer
axes tend to be longer and more focused
on snow and and softer mediums generally
speaking than hard water ice but it's
just tools of the trade and they're all
meant for ice and snow it's not a huge
stretch if I had to rate it I'd give it
like a nine it's pretty accurate
that is in France and it's one of the
coolest ice climbs in the world so they
chose a good ice climb but it's
definitely not the Lula ice fall in
Nepal
[Music]
hello Miss Woods pleasure to make your
acquaintance that is just anatomically
not where you would stop to take a phone
call like ever but it just makes no
sense you'd be like either pulled into
the ice or swinging and her tool is junk
like if you're soloing that is not an
acceptable tool most Ice Climbers will
solo to some degree or another meaning
not use a rope the difference between
soloing and using a rope on ice is a lot
less than the difference between using a
rope and not on Rock ice climbing the
goal is very very much not to fall off
even with a rope because you've got all
these sharp things on you and if you
fall off they tend to catch and either
impale you or break your legs or flip
you upside down and then you break your
neck or your head so you don't fall off
the nice climbing is kind of a general
rule but you want to use much better
technique and tactics than is going on
here this is sketchy represents Wayland
Industries
ice is really strong if you've ever
tried to chip ice off your sidewalk it's
really hard to get off it doesn't all
just like break and catastrophically
fail all the time so yeah it's a good
medium to climb so she's not hitting in
very good places and I can hear the
director saying hit the ice one more
time and make some spray go sideways
because I've done that a lot ice
climbing in movies always looks really
dangerous
and it is dangerous but you can make it
reasonably safe you know wear a helmet
use ropes get qualified instruction it's
a lot of fun in terms of technique and
tactics it's like a two not happening
interestingly I think they actually got
some coaching on how to ice climb their
tools are staggered vertically his tools
are completely buried if he put them in
that deep he's probably never getting
him out like he's gonna have to work for
a very long time but if you look at his
right hand there it's not on the bottom
of the tool it's on the handle of the
tool it's really really hard to just
hang on to the to the to the straight
pipe of the tool you got to get down to
the bottom where that hook is that's
what is for your finger so quite clearly
there is no ice climbing getting done in
this sequence like he's not hanging on
that off that tool he's just standing
there having a conversation
the ice climbing tools are real so we'll
give it a two this is just like eyes
glaze over move on as a nice climber
all right stop stop stop I love this one
because it's not even an attempt to be
realistic there is a thing in climbing
you do called a self-arest but you do it
on like a snow field
[Music]
that's what you wear in the mountains
just like your your Timberland or
whatever they are hiking boots that's
what you want for this type of situation
you know obviously not really probably
want something with a bit more support
and maybe some crampons just as a
thought you know that would that'd be
helpful
[Music]
you use your tools on rock all the time
so mixed climbing is where you climb on
both Rock and ice and it's a natural
part of climbing in the mountains you
have to do that to get up Peaks and it's
become its own kind of weird subsport
I've climbed huge overhanging caves of
of rock and icicles that's totally legit
people do that that's fine you just
don't get to do that after you've been
Free Falling for like 10 seconds
thank you
I love this scene we like this is like
the ultimate combination of parkour and
Ice climbing this one hit the the
climber forums you know out there and
everybody started talking about it right
away because it's totally completely
ridiculous and at the same time it's so
ridiculous it's just kind of awesome
like it's ridiculous and it's laughable
but it's not even trying to be real
what he just did there that's athletic
he's having to deliberately blow his
feet and make it look bad I've taught a
lot of people how to move on ice and if
you can climb a ladder you can you can
ice climb
I have not found that pushing my my
students or guests off the top is the
right way to learn when I teach ice
climbing to people who want to get good
at it I teach them to down climb because
often you'll climb up say 10 feet 3
meters go the wrong way and be like this
is not working out I can either hurl
myself off the ice climb or I can down
climb and safely go another way so it's
a really good skill to have and honestly
it's not practiced enough like that's
probably a nine my favorite ice climbing
movie is is probably K2 I think that
does a pretty accurate job of showing it
for the most part honestly I'm just
stoked when I see ice climbing in a
movie because it's a pretty obscure
sport if you enjoyed this please click
the link above for more videos